[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and this video
are breaking down some brand new plot
leaks for no way home we also have some
theories about when the next trailer is
gonna drop why the poster hasn't been
released yet and what's going on with
the empire images now first up i wanna
talk about when i think the second
trailer is gonna come out for most of
2021 people were sat asking me every
single day when the teaser would be
released and then it finally came out
however it wasn't enough and since then
people have showed up to my house saying
when's the next trailer dropping bro
well you'll get this trailer when you
fix this damn door and no one actually
knows for definite when the new look is
releasing no matter how many people tell
you that it's definitely coming there's
a lot of scoopers on twitter now saying
the trailer is coming soon mate just you
wait and it's like yeah no [ __ ] movie is
out in less than two months kindness is
coming soon now as of making this video
it's the 25th of october and many people
thought that the trailer would come out
today this is because sony recently
added a hidden video to their movies
trailer playlist and empire magazine
dropped a couple of new looks for the
film if i've guessed this whole thing
correctly then the trailer won't release
today and i haven't wasted eight hours
making this video which we'll know
either way by now and i might need to
get out that clown costume now why i
didn't think that it would drop today is
down to a number of reasons firstly the
uncharted trailer was released last
thursday and i didn't think sony would
release teasers for two tom holland
projects less than five days apart the
eternals review embargo also lifted
yesterday and there's no big movie
coming out this friday uncharted was
drop to play in front of june but as for
this week there's not really anything so
i just didn't think it would be coming
out now if i was to hazard a guess i
would say that the first trailer will
probably release next monday to tie in
with the eternals this is just a
guesstimation though so i don't want to
see anyone saying kevin spoilers
confirms spider-man trailer on monday
i've even spoken to people who've said
they might drop it to announce that
tickets for the film are now on sale and
that would come towards the latter half
of november it could also drop the 28th
of october which is when the empire
magazine hit stands but no matter what
anyone says no one knows for definite
now i have spoken to a couple of people
who've said they've seen the new look
and these are the same ones that gave me
info on what would be in the last
trailer if you've watched our leak video
on that then you'll know it lined up a
lot and they've said that marvel and
sony are debating whether to put toby
and andrew in it or not marvel
apparently don't want them too but this
spectacular spoiler man at sony they
just want to blow their load right now
now this kind of ties into why i think
the poster hasn't been released yet
posters are some of the big marketing
tools that a movie has but they also
tend to put not only the faces of the
cast members on it but also their names
from what i've heard william defoe toby
mcguire and andrew garfield all have big
roles in the movie so their names would
probably need to be included on the
poster same situation happened with a
certain actor returning in chongqi so
i'm guessing they're still figuring out
whether they want to announce the
characters in the trailer or on the
poster my theory is that they'll
announce it before the movie comes out
as i think sony will want to get a
picture of all three on the red carpet
at the premiere as that will be such a
historical movie moment willem dafoe is
pretty much known as being in the film
as is andrew garfield who's still
denying it even though we've got him in
4k he's been running away from it but we
know andrew we know you don't have to
say now that kind of takes me onto the
plot leaks and also the empire images
and how they line up if you want to
avoid them then i suggest you act like
andrew garfield when he's asked if he's
the werewolf and just get out of here as
quickly as you can
if you are enjoying the breakdown so far
then we also massively appreciate the
thumbs up and make sure you subscribe if
you want to be a spider menace to
society that's how we get down at the
channel baby now i do i want to do a
basic rundown of the plot points that we
know so far and then drop in some of the
new stuff that's just been posted this
kind of will be covering a lot of things
that i've said before but i don't know
if you've watched my videos or not and i
just thought i'd give as complete of a
breakdown as i possibly can now the
story opens just after peter has been
caught in 4k admitting he's the werewolf
we know it was you andrew swear to me
you punk now peter is mobbed he then
swings across new york with mj and it's
plastered everywhere that he's public
enemy number one peter ends up getting
arrested and along with ned may and mj
they're all questioned about mysterio's
death this is carried out by damage
control and though it was thought to be
the fbi if you look at the logo on the
officer's jacket it's clearly not them
now apparently this is the point where
charlie cox comes into the movie and he
acts as peter's defense lawyer cox
attended comic-con in london this
weekend and some fans have said that
he's confirmed he's in no way home but
we don't have any evidence beyond this
other than hearsay now peter's name is
cleared however he wants to go to mit
but because of his reputation his
applications rejected now this is where
paula newsom's character comes in and
according to one take news she will be
playing an mit administrator it was
theorized that she might be miles
morales mother and this is because of
all the feast trucks that have been
spotted as well as the lines around the
logo in the title reveal which looked a
lot like puerto rico however one take
news have said that she's simply working
at mit and that her character is far
more simple than what we've been told in
the past she rejects peter and this
coupled with everything that's going on
is why he goes to strange to help erase
everyone's memory wong warns him it
could cause some issues but as we've
seen the guy just ignores everything he
says and carries it out anyway now we
all know that peter interrupts the spell
and that this cracks the multiverse open
which allows the villains from across
the spider verse to come into the mcu
however new leaks have said that the
spell doesn't actually work and this is
why the post-credits scene of venom let
there be carnage still shows peter's
identity being reported on the villains
are the green goblin doctor octopus the
lizard sandman the rhino and electro
goblin lies low but the rest of the
villains wreak havoc on new york and
this happens during the bridge scene
that we saw in the first trailer
ironically this bridge is just above the
hudson river which is also the one that
dock died in during the events of
spider-man 2. who knows this scene might
come right off the back of the end of
that movie and we could see him rising
out of the depths of his cold watery
grave now according to the leaks these
are what-if versions of the characters
that aren't the ones we saw in the
original films this means that if you're
a fan of them then they're not going to
wreck on the character development and
also the movies that you love which
let's be honest we love them all even
the bad ones now this is why electro
will be completely different and though
we can't show images of him here because
of copyright reasons if you've seen the
leaks then you'll know he no longer has
his blue skin from what i've been told
by my bro do trust me electro will
arrive in a sort of terminator-esque
entry at a power station and he'll then
steal the clothes off someone at the
site along with their workman jacket
just before the bridge scene peter goes
to the mit administrator and says how he
wants to go to the college and promises
that he won't cause any issues peter is
unaware at this point that the
multiverse is cracked open and this is
when doc hawk attacks so he basically
has to decide whether to fight him and
just prove he's not going to be
spider-man or go out into his costume
and take him on this adds a sort of nice
sacrifice choice for him and as we see
in the trailer he decides to suit up now
peter and strange manage to capture them
and lock them up in a prison right below
the sanctorum during this osborne goes
to them which is when they all bring up
that they remember spider-man being
there when they died osborne then goes
to peter and guilt trips him by saying
that these villains are all dead and
that the peter of their worlds was the
person who killed them if they're sent
back they'll die and once more it'll be
the web head's fault due to this snap he
knows what it's like to be wiped from
existence and he doesn't want to wish
this on anyone peter then steals the
magical cube from the sanctorum that's
holding them in place and this is when
strange chases him across new york in
the mirror dimension because the cube is
gone osborne can free them and they then
launch his attack which is to use a
giant arc reactor to rip a hole in the
multiverse now ned is meant to be the
one that discovers toby and andrew have
been pulled across two in into the
spider verse we saw that someone's dna
can be what brings across variants from
other dimensions and peter's hair being
used in the spell is what connects
everyone to him jacob batalon did tease
something big when reading the script
for no way home and i think that this
moment is when he meets toby and andrew
now they all team up with tom holland's
version and have a fight on the giant
arc reactor which now hovers above the
statue of liberty this has a captain
america's shield on it and it makes for
an awesome action scene i believe that
this was actually teased and the new
empire looks and it could be cobbled
together from lots of different elements
from across the spider verse if we look
closely at the circular object on the
floor it actually looks like it's been
ripped right out of the abandoned dock
building that och was at at the end of
spider-man 2.
should call him dr doctopus
[Music]
anyway they defeat him and strange sends
everyone back before carrying out this
spell without any interruptions this
makes everyone forget and thus peter can
go to mit now it has been said that this
will be the end of the homecoming
trilogy which yeah no [ __ ] mate it's a
trilogy and there's been three movies
however that kind of sets the stage for
the next set of films and it's been said
that they'll have a different tone
because well they're going to be
focusing on peter in college now other
things of now are that there's a big
death and i have been told that this is
may however it's been reported that
multiple endings were filmed so this
could definitely just be swapped out
also some of the six will actually be
good in this and this is why we see
saman protecting peter from electro in
the trailer
anyway that wraps it up and like i said
couple of new bits in there along with
the general leaks though i know i've
been repeating some i don't know which
of my videos you've watched and which
ones you haven't so i'm repeating myself
again by telling you that i think the
movie does sound great and though we
won't know if these are legit for some
time i would absolutely love to see them
in the film obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on them whether you think
they're real whether you think they're
fake so yeah just let me know in the
comment section below we are in
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the phase 3 mcu boxer on
the 30th of october and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video we
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want some else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of the
uncharted trailer which will be linked
on screen right now we went over it from
top to bottom and pointed out all the
easter eggs we could find so if you're
interested in that movie then definitely
go watch it after this if not then
thanks for sticking through the video
i've been paul and i'll see you on the
next one take care peace